so the people who don't know what's the
goal of your movement
it's obviously Cola to overthrow the
regime and bring about Democratic
pluralistic secular regimes inside Iran
but rather we pray God that we can
change the regime absolutely peacefully
because we have enough martyrs 120
thousands of our members and supporters
have been killed we by the regime and we
don't want to add to this list we are
trying to increase the support of
Iranian people inside Iran very much
depends on what will happen in Iran when
I first met you in ashram I mean you had
entire tank we have battalions and
brigades you had a fervent belief that
through military action you could spark
the fire of revolution have you
abandoned that now the prospect of armed
resistance armed revolution it's many
years that we have not been engaged in
any military activities that has been
publicly announced okay so why does a
political organization still need to
have a paramilitary organisation then it
has never been a paramilitary well
you've had a political face and you've
had a military files yes you are very
well armed you were very well trained as
a fighting force you were a very
impressive organisation exactly you have
watch 3,800 members still in uniform so
to speak right very beautiful basically
nonetheless you so have not abandoned
the notion of armed resistance should
moment arise should the opportunity
present itself if you ask me as a matter
of principle I believe the people's
right to resistance better that's in the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
that's in the American independence you
can see now he's going all the way to
the American Constitution so that's a
principle
[Music]